[Music]
let's roll out to Montana and talk to
Sweet Sweet Ann what's up
an hi John baloney what's up how are
you I had chocolate chip cookies and
milk for breakfast so I am fantastic how
are you ah dude I'm kind of jealous
right now I was doing fine and so you
just said that I had eggs and apple and
protein shake like an
idiot man all right so good for you and
so uh we'll prepare for the sugar crash
here in a bit we'll try to get through
this call fast so you can land safely
from your crash what's
up uh I have a question about how do I
set boundaries with friends go for it
what happened great uh so the boundary
is one of my best friends is a guy and I
have a fantastic boyfriend who I really
want to honor and make feel comfortable
and this one relationship and the way we
interact doesn't make him feel
comfortable so some boundaries that we
have set is Luke and I just the the
friend aren't gonna hang out oneon-one
anymore hold on we'll go back I'll edit
that part out okay we'll make a note to
edit his name out um so oh it's a fake
name oh it's a fake name okay cool all
right never mind then all right so Luke
all right yep uh so
Luke oh no
uh where was I oh you're just telling me
so you and your boyfriend have made some
boundaries so your boyfriend can feel
comfortable oh yes so Luke and I just
aren't going to hang out oneon-one
anymore and when I interact with him
just a little bit less playful and less
flirty so I've had no problem
implementing these boundaries without
saying a word to Luke and but the thing
is I really don't like that it's making
me feel like a bad friend because like I
just kind of casually keep blowing him
off and avoiding him in awkward ways but
every time I try to like practice saying
the words out loud I either feel like a
hypocrite or I
overshare so I could use some help
practicing that well I think the deeper
question I have for you is this are
these your rules that you see no this is
healthy and right or are you trying to
make somebody happy this is both of us
this is what we agreed upon that's not
what I asked well played nice try
an well it was a discussion I'll miss
his friendship a little bit but I can
also see how it does come off that
way and so I also like these rules this
seems like the right direction for us to
go something doesn't feel right to
me oh well that's
unfortunate
so like let's take your conversation
with your current boyfriend off the
table okay one of your best friends in
the the world happen happens to be a guy
you laugh you all go hang out and have
coffee whatever absolutely no sexual
chemistry at all is that what you're
saying uh not on my side and so this is
where it comes in both the boyfriend and
I agree that it would not
be out of the ballpark or totally
abnormal if this friend did have a crush
on me if Luke had a crush on me he would
be like oh yeah no that kind of makes
sense nothing from my side for years
while I knew this man and I never asked
him out a single time I got nothing did
he ask you out nope okay would he if you
just called him tonight and you're like
I I can't believe this I've missed it
you're right under my nose this whole
time I love you what would he
say probably yes but I guess I don't
know
okay I think that um we can be cruel
when we know somebody has feelings for
us and we kind of play right up against
the line
there and we know that there's like this
weird unspoken tension we know you know
kind of but not really but maybe but not
really okay there's I mean that
definitely is where the oversharing
comes in tell me about oversharing what
do you mean by that oh well like if I
went to set these boundaries the thing
is the one-on-one rule would make me
feel like a hypocrite because like I
would still go hang out with some of my
other guy friends just the two of us
there's no issues there
but there would be issues with Cam
because of the fact that we both see
that type of relationship being a
possibility both the boyfriend and I
think that would be
possible so for me to set the clear
boundary of like hey I don't want to
hang out one any on oneon-one
anymore
because we think that our relationship
is too close that feels weird to
overshare like that it feels weird that
you keep having to use a
plural oh I can take the boyfriend out
of it if you would like well it's not
for me I don't I mean I'm going to sleep
just fine
tonight it sounds like you kind of have
a crush on this dude and you know it's
not great if you're dating somebody else
am I wrong on no crush on him huh no
Crush nothing okay
so is it just that like full like full
disclosure is it just that your
boyfriend's uncomfortable with him this
gets a bad from that dude oh well they
are friends outside of it he just thinks
that Luke and I have a slightly flirty
relationship oh this is so weird I don't
I don't know what to tell you because
here's what I'm trying to paint a
picture
if there's a couple of different buckets
here bucket number one is you don't owe
anybody an explanation for any of your
choices you can tell anybody at any time
hey I just um
I'm dating this guy I'm going to quit
going on 101's just me and
you I'm just going to stop okay it just
doesn't feel right and I like you you're
my friend you've been my friend for a
long time I'm just not going to go out
to coffee with you
anymore and then if you have another
person that you work with and you'll go
run grab lunch and he sees it and he's
like wait a minute you said and you
could say no I said to
you you and I have been friends for a
long time we've got a deeper
relationship this whole thing is just
kind of
weird okay see what I'm saying that's
one that works for me number two is if
you're dating somebody and they just get
that gut feeling watch out for that
dude I've learned to honor that I used
to be like whatever uhuh that's not real
I've learned to honor
that three is like the third vertical
here
is maybe it's time if you and the this
guy are getting serious maybe it's time
to say I'm just going to quit going to
have lunches or going to have drinks
with just dudes just me and
them just kind of as a way of being I'm
going to honor our you I'm going to
honor our
relationship I'm going to take all the
confusion out of all of
this okay the only place I get stuck
with that one is I go hiking with guys
and I don't want to be eaten by a
grizzly bear but outside of that I could
honor and respect that I like the way
that works I would hope you don't get
eaten by grizzly bear yes remember the
rule of hiking in Grizzlies you don't
have to outrun the grizzly you just have
to outrun the slowest other person
there well that a man I had cookies for
breakfast John deloney I might be that
person but listen like the
uh I don't know an it feels like there's
something else here no I liked what you
said John you hit it on the head I don't
owe an explanation
I just hey these are the
boundaries yeah this is what I'm
choosing to live by I don't have to
explain why it's different for some
people or why relationships end up
different ways no but I
also I don't want you to just move from
one situation to another
either I don't want you draw a boundary
with one guy that you've had a good
relationship with and then all of a
sudden you you start hiking with these
dud other dudes all the time and then
suddenly they get an idea like oh she's
kind of into us too she calls wants to
hang out a lot now and that turns into
and your boyfriend's in like dude okay
well can you not do that
too I have been looking for lots of
friends it's been a working progress
there you go that's probably
Fair the whole I I I
would some people have blanket rules I
I'm dating somebody or I'm married to
somebody so I will not have friends of
the opposite
gender I think that's very very hard to
do in the modern world I
also have seen people be very flippant
with that and find themselves in a world
of trouble I would never cheat on on so
and so yeah but they would now we got a
mess
right and sometimes somebody comes into
a relationship and y'all are dating and
it's all good but from the outside it
just kind of doesn't feel right it looks
weird it's like hey you're always going
out in having chips and queso you're
always going out and hanging out you
always going out and having a drink
always just makes me feel uncomfortable
and if we're going to date like I want
it just to be us that goes out and does
10 on- ones cool all right I'll end that
but I'm gonna go hiking with these guys
I'm gonna go do this with these guys and
I'm gonna go do that with those guys
well the whole thing just gets murky I
would challenge you and your current
boyfriend to sit down and say what are
our values who are we going to be
besides just this guy what are what are
things that make you
uncomfortable what are the things that
make you
uncomfortable I would not head off to
the woods to go hiking with just like
three other women while my wife was like
all right you guys have fun I just
wouldn't do that that whole thing L
would not be
great and like it's not weird for Kelly
I to go have a meeting downstairs in the
cafeteria while she drinks her straight
bourbon and I have coffee in the middle
of the work day while she's getting
tattooed none of those things are true
so there's a balance here and everybody
listening is going to have an opinion
and a thought like oh my gosh I can't I
think it's just coming up with your own
values the one thing I get nervous about
is an overly zealous overbearing partner
who begins to control your time who you
see where you go what you think is
funny and I get nervous about that but
not my
relationship just set your boundaries
and set your Val use firm and um you'll
go from
there